Movies often end on cliffhangers or by hinting
towards things to come, but sometimes those
endings can be quite dense and confusing for
audiences.
Examples are particularly prominent in - although
not exclusive to - the world of comic book
movies, because the endings will often hint
towards new characters from the comic books
that mainstream movie audiences might not
be familiar with.Of course, these days, movies
don't necessarily "end" at the point that
they're traditionally supposed to.
Back in the day, a movie would end and the
rolling of the credits would be the cue for
audiences to stop watching, but mid and post-credits
scenes are extremely common these days - and
these scenes can often explain (or at least
hint towards) the future of the franchise
in question.In this article, we'll take a
look at ten movies that ended in a way that
suggested "something" was going to happen
in the future - whether it be in a credits
scene or otherwise - and we'll explain exactly
what that "something" is going to be.
Please note that there will be some spoilers
for a number of movies released in 2016.
Captain America: Civil War
A lot happened at the end of Captain America:
Civil War.
Heroes went off in all kinds of different
directions and there were two scenes after
the credits rolled, so let's cut to the chase
here; The Avengers now officially only consist
of Iron Man, a recovering War Machine and
Vision.
Black Widow is on the run for helping Bucky
and Captain America escape, despite having
been on Iron Man's team.
As per the mid-credits scene, Black Panther,
also despite having been on Iron Man's team,
has taken Captain America and Bucky Barnes
to Wakanda, granting them both asylum and
putting Barnes back in cryogenic stasis until
his brainwashing can be cured.
The rest of Team Captain America are on the
run - including Ant-Man, who may well be a
fugitive when his next movie with the Wasp
comes around.
And, as per the post-credits scene, Spider-Man
is back in Queens in possession of a high-tech
gadget that would suggest Tony Stark is going
to be helping him in the future.
Got all that?
Good.
Inception
Dom Cobb, the character played by Leonardo
DiCaprio in Inception, may not exactly be
a traditional "hero" given that he's a thief,
but he's the protagonist of the movie and
the guy you're rooting for, so he certainly
fits the bill here.
For the entire movie, Cobb concerned himself
with whether or not he was dreaming or in
reality, and his totem - a spinning top - would
tell him in either case.
If it kept spinning, Cobb was dreaming.
If it fell, he was awake.
The movie ended ambiguously, with Cobb walking
away from his spinning totem after seeing
his children, and the entire point of that
scene - as explained long after the movie's
release by director Christopher Nolan - was
that Cobb no longer cared whether he was dreaming
or awake, because he was happy with his life
regardless.
The Thing
John Carpenter's horror classic The Thing
was about a parasitic extraterrestrial lifeform
that assimilates other organisms and subsequently
imitates them.
It infiltrated an Antarctic research station
and, at the end of the movie, only two members
of the research team were left alive - Keith
Davids' Childs and Kurt Russell's MacReady
- and while it's obvious that one of them
must have been assimilated, it's confusing
trying to fathom which one it is.
However, there is a subtle clue in the form
of some foreshadowing earlier in the movie.
MacReady handed a drink to a cheating chess
computer and, as he and Childs sit as the
only survivors, he does the same to Childs.
The parallels are obvious: Macready is the
strategist calling the shots and he has the
alien all figured out.
Unfortunately, however, that probably means
he was assimilated shortly after the movie
ended - after all, he was in the middle of
nowhere with nobody there to help him.
X-Men: Apocalypse
X-Men: Apocalypse is getting something of
a grilling from movie critics, but that doesn't
mean that the movie didn't leave a lot of
exciting hints about the franchise going forward.
For starters, it looks like we're going to
see Dark Phoenix in the future, as Apocalypse
saying "all is revealed" as Jean Grey unleashed
her power was very ominous - as was her nightmare
that shook the X-Mansion.
You also have to expect that Quicksilver will
reveal himself to Magneto as his son at some
point - and that will certainly result in
an intriguing relationship.
Psylocke made a hasty escape after Apocalypse
was defeated - there's every chance she might
join up with Deadpool and Cable in an X-Force
movie in future, which would be awesome.
However, the most exciting thing came in the
post-credits scene, as the reveal of a briefcase
marked "Essex Corp" in the Weapon X facility
hinted towards the future appearance of Nathaniel
Essex - Mister Sinister himself - as a future
big-bad in the franchise.
That will be absolutely amazing to see.
Birdman
Birdman follows the exploits of a faded actor
called Riggan Thomson, played by Michael Keaton,
as he struggles to come to terms with the
fact that his fame isn't what it once was.
Most famous for playing the titular superhero
character Birdman, Thomson's frail mental
state has resulted in him seeing the character
in hallucinations.
Towards the end of the movie, Thomson found
peace after landing a role on Broadway.
Satisfied with life, and wanting to give an
extra real performance, Thomson replaces a
prop gun with a loaded gun in a suicide scene
and actually shoots himself in the head.
He doesn't die, however, and is later seen
recovering in hospital.
The last time we see the character, he opens
the window of his hospital room and is never
seen again.
In the final scene, his daughter Sam walks
up to the window, looks down, then looks to
the sky and smiles.
Although it's quite tragic, what actually
happened is that Sam saw her father's spirit
heading to heaven, where he will spend eternity
in happiness.
Total Recall
Total Recall tells the story of Douglas Quaid,
a construction worker in 2084 played by Arnold
Schwarzengegger who is having troubling dreams
about Mars and a mysterious woman there.
At a company called Rekall that provides memory
implants of vacations, Quaid decides to take
a fantasy memory trip as a secret agent to
Mars.
Something goes wrong with his implant, however,
and from then on the story continuously asks
the question of what is real and what is hallucination.
At the movie's climax, it is left ambiguous
as to whether Quaid is dreaming or in reality,
but Paul Verhoeven - the movie's director
- has claimed that everything is taking place
in Quaid's head and he's been rendered permanently
stuck like that, thanks to the his brain having
a violent reaction to the implant process
and including aspects of his real life into
his fantasy trip.
This makes a lot of sense, as far too many
coincidences take place for everything that
goes on to be real.
Guardians of the Galaxy
The ending to Guardians of the Galaxy wasn't
confusing, per se, but there were some important
things (and some things that probably aren't
so important in the long-term) that you may
have missed.
You will no doubt have caught Rocket Raccoon
holding a sapling, and seen mini-Groot dancing
behind Drax's back, so you'll know the lovable
tree-like humanoid is returning in the sequel,
but did you catch the post-credits scene?
The Collector was in his destroyed museum
with two characters from the comic books - Howard
the Duck and Cosmo the Spacedog, who we may
meet again in the future - but the scene served
as a timely reminder of the coming of a much
more important character in the franchise.
We had previously seen a cocoon in the museum,
but the devastation caused when it was destroyed
will more than likely have seen the character
inside it disturbed from his regenerative
hibernation.
That character is Adam Warlock - and he will
be a key character going forward in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as a whole, as he will
meet the Guardians of the Galaxy in their
sequel and his participation alongside them
in the fight against Thanos in the Avengers:
Infinity War movies will be decisive when
it comes to defeating the Mad Titan.
The Matrix Revolutions
If you can understand most of what happened
in the three Matrix movies, well done to you,
but nobody can know for sure exactly what
happened at the end of The Matrix Revolutions
- that is apart from the Wachowski Brothers
who wrote it, of course.
An explanation actually comes from a cut scene
in the video game The Matrix: The Path of
Neo, in which pixelated representations of
the brothers say this: "Neo stands on the
verge of satori, ready to resolve the parodox
of choice and choicelessness, free will versus
fate, but that can only be achieved through
an act of surrender, which occurs after an
abandonment of the perspectile nature of truth,
accepting the totality of present consciousness
which ultimately allows an evolutionary transition,
transcending the Cartesian Dilemma through
emergence of de-limited spirit which then
provides the world with a third path, the
Path of Neo, the path of peace."
And if that doesn't clear it up for you, basically,
by referencing a lot of Eastern philosophies,
the Wachowskis are saying that Neo's mind
and spirit have likely transcended into the
Matrix, covering it like a guardian angel
or holy ghost.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
In Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice, Superman
was killed in battle against the monstrous
Doomsday - a being created using the corpse
of General Zod from Man of Steel and the DNA
of Lex Luthor.
As a tribute to his fallen fellow hero, Batman
vowed to assemble a team of metahumans to
battle evil from that point onwards.
This was, of course, foreshadowing the coming
of the Justice League to our cinema screens
and we will see the likes of Wonder Woman,
the Flash, Aquaman and Cyborg in the team
in the future.
But something else happened at the end of
Batman v Superman - a faint heartbeat was
heard and the dirt around Superman's coffin
began to levitate!
Superman isn't actually dead!
In Man of Steel, particles of ice levitated
around Superman the first time he flew, so
this is a throwback to that moment - and a
sure sign that Superman will fly again.
Moreover, in the Death of Superman comic book
arc, Superman didn't stay dead for too long
after a fatal collision with Doomsday - and
you can rest assured he won't in the movies
either.
Deadpool
After the credits rolled in the brilliant
Deadpool movie, the titular character re-emerged
on screen from the bedroom of Ferris Bueller
from Ferris Bueller's Day Off, wearing a bathrobe
identical to the one Ferris wore.
After some typically humorous babbling from
Ryan Reynolds' character, he explains that
there will be a sequel to the movie and that
Cable will be in it.
But exactly who is Cable?
Casual audiences probably don't know the character,
but he is iconic in Marvel's comic books.
He's the telekinetic son of Cyclops and a
clone of Jean Grey called Madelyne Pryor - but
he can also time-travel - and he's actually
appeared in a comic book title called "Cable
and Deadpool".
As he's from the future, expect him to travel
back in time to join Deadpool for some violent
capers in the sequel.
You also have to imagine that Wolverine will
appear alongside them in Deadpool's second
movie, given how many references to the character
were made in the first one.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 confusing
movie endings and what's next for the heroes
who starred in them.
Did you enjoy this video?
Did it clear anything up for you?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.